I'm spending today trying to figure out
which of these five people is actually
drunk Juliet oh Juliet we're poor art
thou all right sorry
the last bar I went to it was probably
like West Hollywood you seem to be the
cool calm collected one of this group
definitely I'm I'm Libra all the way
through man I just want to be killed
yeah I just turned 21. I literally like
I'm not dealing with
him I said I'm being honest I don't
understand why you're not like
can we talk like what what's our beef
we're not at the house in three months
no I was just at Trader Joe's they had
tequila they have tequila yes but I but
I have I don't have room in my fridge I
feel like what happens when you dream
you have like fun easy conversations and
the easiest fun conversation I had was
with Irish I'm gonna guess it's because
he's a little tipsy and that's my final
answer
hey yo sis what's up